قرار لنقابه المحامين في بيروت تحول
عنوانا لمعركه حريه
محامون وحقوقيون تداعوا ضد الزام المحامي
باستئذان النقابه قبل الادلاء باي تصريح
في وسائل الاعلام انا محامي حر المحامون
المعترضون تقدموا بطعن قضائي في القرار
ومنهم من تحداه بمخالفته فتحركت النقابه
عبر استدعاء عدد منهم مش ممكن انك انت
تسكت المحامين بالعكس لازم تضمن انه
المحامين يكونوا احرار تيقدروا يعبروا عن
مشاغل الناس وهموم وعبر عن الناس اللي
بعدهم ناطرين العداله ويحذروا المحامون من
احتمال حصر الاذن فيما يتوافق مع مصالح
حزبيه وسياسيه يقضي قرار نقابه المحامين
بتعديل نظام اداب المهنه والزام المحامي
بالحصول على اذن مسبق من النقيب قبل
الظهور في الاعلام او مناقشه المسائل
القانونيه في الندوات وعلى مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي كما يمنع القرار المحامي من
انتقاد النقيب ومجلس النقاب لاسيما اثناء
الانتخابات النقابيه
للنقابه مبرراتها فللحريات قواعد واصول
وفق قولها يؤدي سوء استخدامها لما سمته
بالفوضى واوضحت ان القراره لا يشمل
الاطلالات الاعلاميه للمحامين حول قضايا
سياسيه او ثقافيه او اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
ما رايناه مؤخرا من بعض
اذا لا يمكن القبول
بتناول ملفات قضائيه ما تزال قيد النظر
امام المحاكم
القرار ياتي على خلفيه تزايد ظهور
الاعلامي للمحامين الناشطين في الشان
العام لا سيما في القضايا المتعلقه
بانفجار مرفا بيروت وحقوق المودعين في
المصارف وقضايا فساد واستنقسامات سياسيه
وقضائيه وما اخذ على ما يسميه المعترضون
بنفوذ الاحزاب السياسيه في النقابات كافه
النقابات في لبنان لم تمارس اي استقلاليه
عن المنظومه السياسيه بشكل كامل وهذا
يستدعي عمليا اعاده النظر بالتدخل السياسي
في النقابات ولكن ايضا دور النقابات في
حمايه الحريات العامه والحوكمه السليمه
اعاده النظر في واقع النقابات ترتبط
بتصحيح الواقع السياسي برمته لا سيما ان
الخشيه على الحريات العامه وفق المعترضين
لا تقفوا عند باب نقابه المحامين بل
تتعداه الى مجالات اخرى تزداد توسعا مع
اشتداد الازمات السياسيه في البلاد كتر
حنا الجزيره بيروت